why did dumbledore groom harry to die
how could they trust student safety to a
werewolf and is slytherin's hatred and
distrust of the other houses justified
keep watching to find out
former death eater or not seeking out a
job working with children to procure the
power you never had as a kid isn't a
cute or defensible move fans tend to
give severus snape a pass on his
questionable behavior as a teacher
because he turns on voldemort to become
a double agent for dumbledore yet his
motives to betray voldemort have little
to do with nobility snape was angry that
voldemort killed lily but he was all too
happy to let james and harry die to snag
the one that got away for himself
that's not love and just because he
saves harry's life a few times doesn't
excuse bullying a child because he looks
like his dad and it's not just harry
that snape lords over like a classroom
bully who's still reliving his glory
days
neville's boggart proves that he's more
afraid of snape than the woman who
tortured his parents into insanity which
is horrifying to say the least despite
the fandom's romanticization of snape
his few heroic moments and his obsession
over a woman who told him no don't erase
his cruelty toward his students
you'd be hard-pressed to find a harry
potter fan who doesn't love rubius
hagrid but that doesn't mean that he's
without his faults hagrid's love for
magical creatures may be legendary but
he doesn't always put their needs ahead
of his own selfishness should hagrid be
keeping a dragon as a pet or chaining up
a three-headed dog in a tiny room to
protect a treasure absolutely not in
fact hagrid's love for creatures
endlessly puts their lives at risk and
the lives of his students whether he's
risking the life of aragog the arachnid
he saved by smuggling him in the castle
when he's a hogwarts student or bringing
a hippogriff to his unruly classroom
quite a few animals would have been
better off not knowing him buckbeak
nearly dies because of hagrid's
negligence when buckbeak was just doing
what's in its nature between that and
drinking copious amounts of alcohol
around students our favorite half giant
isn't so cuddly after all
by dumbledore's estimations sybil
trelawny has made precisely two real
predictions during her tenure at
hogwarts the prophecy regarding
voldemort's vanquisher and the prisoner
of azkaban prophecy where she predicts
the return of peter pettigrew he who
betrayed his friends
with murder shall break free
innocent blood shall be spilt
given that trey lonnie doesn't even
remember her actual predictions she's
either an intentional fraud who likes to
toy with her students for dramatic
effect or she's convinced herself to
believe her own mind games either way
she treats her students like pawns in a
metaphysical experiment and she also
emotionally abuses hermione just because
she's a bit of a know-it-all
calling a student's soul as dry as a
book is pretty gross if your student
questions the legitimacy of your subject
you don't lash out and eviscerate their
self-confidence their children be an
adult
remus lupin is hands down the school's
most competent defense against the dark
arts teacher that we see throughout the
series but why is he left to howl at the
moon on hogwarts grounds at all having
the guy hide in a tree during full moons
when he turns into a werewolf in a
castle full of students is questionable
judgment at best lupin's wolfy
characteristics certainly aren't his
fault but for a couple of days out of
the month he shouldn't be anywhere near
students especially not when the ever
vindictive snape is in charge of his
symptom-relieving potion during
transitions he should be in a safe
secluded space to protect himself and
everyone around him instead both he and
dumbledore leave things to fate and
harry and his friends almost die for it
lupin's situation is quite tragic given
how little control he has over his own
body but that doesn't excuse him from
bearing the responsibility of ensuring
his student's safety before he turns
each month and loses all will
the bar is pretty low for hogwarts
professors but even educators like
slughorn leave a lot to be desired
sure slughorn is competent when you
measure him against the dude who wears
voldemort as a fashionable headpiece but
on his own slughorn's a pretty awful
teacher slughorn uses his students to
feed his narcissism taking credit for
their accomplishments and displaying
them in his classroom like trophies that
he personally won he even creates a
creepy elite club for his star students
ok we get it hogwarts terrible safety
track record makes open positions
difficult to fill but you can't just
hire terrible people because you can't
fill a position even slughorn himself
doesn't want to take the job someone
really needs to assist dumbledore on the
hiring process because his track record
is pretty bad
albus dumbledore made an alarming number
of mistakes and oversights during his
time at hogwarts
still none are quite as sinister as what
he does to the wizarding world's golden
boy harry potter in his calculated quest
to defeat voldemort dumbledore raises
harry to be a martyr for the slaughter
while never being completely honest with
him putting harry in grave danger
annually for reasons the boy never fully
understands harry risks his life time
and time again to fix the mistakes of
the negligent hogwarts staff yet even
when dumbledore takes him on perilous
horcrux missions dumbledore still keeps
the young wizard in the dark probably
because his master plan requires harry
to die at the right time in order to
destroy the last horcrux it's frankly a
shock that harry even lives long enough
to carry out that insane plan but the
fact that dumbledore secretly maneuvers
harry into sacrificing himself is also
pretty shocking
despite the fact that voldemort cursed
the defense against the dark arts
position dumbledore still does little to
no vetting when he fills the open
position
instead he continually hires incompetent
or straight-up evil wizards to teach the
school's most important subject
as it stands we've got professors dying
some acting as voldemort's right-hand
face and a narcissist who obliviates
iconic wizards to steal their life story
just to name a few it's wild that
dumbledore is supposed to be the
greatest wizard in his time yet he can't
be bothered to lift a curse or come up
with a clever way around it hell cedric
diggory would still be alive if
dumbledore instilled some anti-polyjuice
potion measures to prevent identity
theft in a magic school use your big
brain dumbledore
apparently the forbidden forest is only
forbidden when professors aren't hosting
detention there in the sorcerer's stone
harry ron and hermione get caught out of
bed when malfoy snitches on them genius
that he is he gets lumped into the
detention crew himself by tattling
instead of doing something normal like
writing lines the four students get
separated into groups to hunt down a
unicorn killer in a cursed forest
what the heck are these teachers
thinking the forest isn't the only
esoteric punishment of the castle though
phil treminous is about the good old
days when he got to hang students up in
the dungeons and there's also dolores
umbridge who enjoys making students
write lines that get carved into their
skin with a sick quill a charming
sleight of staff huh
with the level of house favoritism
hogwarts professors exhibit when they
award or detract points for the house
cup the tradition is all but rigged
a few professors like mcgonagall seem to
keep things fair but even she shows her
gryffindor cards on occasion
snape is less than subtle about his
determination to detract every possible
point from gryffindor while awarding
slytherin points whenever he can and
he's not the only one are you incapable
of restraining yourself or do you take
pride in being an insufferable
know-it-all
he's got a point you know five points
from gryffindor
however dumbledore gets the award for
the worst case of points tampering we've
ever seen it's bad enough when
professors dole out unfair points
throughout the year but dumbledore needs
to make a whole dramatic show of things
in sorcerer's stone gryffindors are dead
last until dumbledore baits and switches
the celebrating slytherins by publicly
awarding harry a bunch of points for
straight-up murdering quarrel ron for
playing a great game of overdramatic
chess hermione for being a cool witch
and neville for standing up to his
friends
of course he does this after announcing
slytherin as the winner no wonder
slytherins are always so pissy the
headmaster of the school literally pits
every house against them gryffindor
the house cup
in the hogwarts professor's quest to put
their students in as much peril as
wizardly possible they put on a
dangerous and occasionally deadly
international tournament between
teenaged martyrs despite the original
tri-wizards tournament's demise due to
the death of teenagers the wizard
schools decide that this is a swell time
to bring the tradition back in goblet of
fire it might as well be the hunger
games
based on what we know it doesn't seem
like the professors or headmasters do a
single thing to make it safer this go
around and what do you know cedric
diggory pays the price with his life
sure having three international schools
compete in a tournament to learn about
different cultures and gain new
experiences is a great idea however
there doesn't need to be a death
component with dragons and other
dangerously unpredictable tasks to do so
the tournament also leads to
dumbledore's most out of character
moment in the film
how did you put your name in a couple of
the fire
that's one of the oldest students to do
it for you
you're absolutely sure
despite his outrage in the movie in the
books dumbledore already knows that
harry isn't advanced enough to fool the
goblets age barrier suffice to say it's
not one of dumbledore's best moments
from the films and the tournament is
just as deadly as it was in years past
because the professors couldn't keep a
tighter watch on things
with a headmaster as experienced as
dumbledore you'd think that he'd be more
than willing to take the lead on any
investigative work when all is not well
at hogwarts yet no matter how many times
harry ron and hermione bring serious
situations to the school's attention
they brush it off
in the end the educators always leave a
bunch of kids to do the dirty work of
hogwarts negligent professors the
hogwarts teachers openly let their
students fight their battles while
rarely lifting a finger to handle
situations themselves
why because of their ego trip of course
if they haven't noticed anything
themselves how on earth could something
possibly be funky one time would be more
than enough but even hogwarts best
professors like mcgonagall gaslight
students about any serious concerns
without ever doing anything substantial
when it comes to the final battle the
students are somehow still taking charge
when many of the remaining professors
don't do all that much to help out just
look at the death toll of students
compared to professors there are far too
many crises at the school to begin with
but why is there rarely a professor
around when shady wizard drama is going
down
[Music]
the professors continually say that
hogwarts is the safest place in the
wizarding world but that assumption is
precisely what causes them to frequently
put students lives in danger by being
complacent hiding a three-headed dog and
the sorcerer's stone in the castle was a
major lack of judgment and it was just
one of many
sirius black manages to infiltrate the
school peter pettigrew runs around as
the weasley's rat for years and death
eaters can stroll in whenever they want
if an old map that a bunch of
mischievous kids created can detect
someone who's supposed to be dead why
aren't more measures like that taken by
actual professors for an impenetrable
school a whole lot of devious wizards
managed to infiltrate how is this a safe
school and why aren't the professors and
its headmaster taking these breaches and
security seriously how many students
have to die before professors stop
toting the there's no safer place
tagline and actually pay attention to
what's happening around them if harry
potter the world's most oblivious wizard
notices a problem when the teachers
don't that's definitely a red flag even
the repetition of tragic historical
events goes unbothered by the staff at
the first sign of the chamber's
reopening the school should be evacuated
let alone after multiple petrified
students are discovered one wrong glance
and the school would have a dozen more
moaning myrtles it's a miracle it takes
so long before parents start pulling
their kids from school check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]